ted the pga tour superstore fitting van
experience
is the ultimate in custom club fitting
and helps you get the most out of your
game
i visited the pga tour superstore who is
sponsoring this segment
to try out a private one-on-one session
[Music]
from beginner to expert the pga tour
superstore has something for everyone
and today
i'm out to find the perfect club bobby
good to see you buddy is this is this a
good club
this is an amazing golf club for a good
golfer like yourself but
if we're gonna find out what's proper
and the best suited for you we need to
go through a fitting appointment set
two days from today if you can bring
with you your current clubs appropriate
attire and some comfortable shoes
and we'll get you some new golf sticks i
can do it then you take this one thank
you every couple days bobby
in a couple
bobby i'm so excited to be trying this
today i got my outfit is on point thanks
to you guys and
you call it a toolbox i got a new
toolbox but i need new tools this is
unbelievable you bought a beautiful
bag and you got these dinosaurs they
were like a hand-me-down for a buddy of
mine
they work for me but i'm ready to get
some new clubs we're gonna get it done
all right what do we do we're gonna
start with the driver today because
that's what we signed up with
right now we're in the tour van fitting
area we have a launch monitor that's
going to read
all of our parameters for when we do our
driver fitting
launch angle back spins club head speed
attack angle
path angle every number that we need to
dial in a driver
so for you i need you to loosen up a
little bit stretch out hit a couple
we'll go through your numbers and i'll
build you a new driver
beautiful great contact yeah it went to
the right
you and 95 percent of all the golfers so
my number's now going to show up here
yes sir fast and everything yep the face
angle presentation 8.7 open mainly why
that ball went to the right
but what i'm not worried about in the
club fitting i worry about your club
head speed to help you make sure you
have the proper
shaft i worry about your launch angle
and your backspin that we have the right
law
and the right center of gravity in the
drivers you walked in here with a 13
degree driver
with a men's senior shift we're going to
go into a men's regular 10 and a half
degree driver that's it let's take it
away all right dialed in okay so
come back up and hit the ball again
let's go okay you get your spot over
there
here we go
beauty jc beauty look at it right down
the line
match the shift for you wow now you can
go have fun with your buddies that's
incredible
the first shot was way to the right the
first one to me was right down the line
was it not
right in the middle of fairway how my
numbers look are they better than nine
yards offline okay that's great not
worried about the distance i'm not a
distance chaser i like to see the golf
ball get in the middle of the fairway
your clubhead speed went up to 84 miles
an hour yes it did yep
backspin still a little high that one we
hit a little high a little off the heel
so in golf the strike location also
dictates
some of the spin that ball you hit a
little bit high inner quad heel which
made the ball spin high
i'm just happy you made it go straight
all by just tweaking my club bobby i
will take this
driver uh what if i want us to do irons
irons we go
same procedure we're gonna come back in
pointman only base we're going to go
through
different shafts lengths lies weights
kick points
torques and even all different head
models we have different variety of
manufacturers to work with so
whenever you want to come back in i'll
get you dialed in perfect you carry my
clubs out i got you let's do it come on
i love caddying i'll tip you no problem
it was good it was fun today
i did tip them actually for more
information on the fitting van
experience at the pga tour
superstore who sponsored this segment
call them at 725-867
or visit pgatoursuperstore.com